when Christoph Gastner started his
maritime career it was usual to transmit
a short report ashore just once a day
now things are very different with crews
constantly receiving new information
pipelines my plants can be moved or
completed there are oil rigs to think
about summer moved often so it's quite
important to us to keep up with the
latest conditions the film actor in
stamford a good internet connection with
high quality antennas makes it all
possible the company knows exactly where
the cat San Lorenzo is located and how
much fuel the ship's consuming my kind
of tzatziki hot blushing darling look at
the key machinery data here are now
officers as well as the cylinder
pressure and temperatures that allows us
to assess whether the machinery needs
maintenance BOTS orphan marine
transmission producer ranchers knows
that maintenance is a huge cost factor
the transmissions usually only need
maintenance every few years but the
unexpected can be a huge problem what
comes from there can be an abrasion in
the gears or the bearings when the wrong
oil is used then been modified should
have ended word sensors like this should
help in the future ranches is testing
them on their transmissions and wants to
launch the early warning system in two
or three years the sensors oversee the
transmissions temperature pressure and
acceleration you pronate illegally we
can collect the data regularly and
continuously evaluate them with
algorithms and then analyze them one
that allows us to recognize damage early
and we can inform the shipping company
the owner and the captain when there
could be a referal damage and then
provide the spare parts in the
appropriate time left side gauge meter
that's saying kazhagam shipping
companies like hamburg sued believe the
digitalization of ships offers
advantages on board the capsule lorenza
more than a thousand sensors transmit
large amounts of data but it's not ready
to steer the ship from land
as I veins may only monitoring the data
we're still not navigating if somebody
hacked into the system they could look
at the data but not take control of the
ship like turn off the main engine of
yours open the ship's crew welcomes the
updated technology the younger
generation can't imagine receiving
emails from home just once a day like
the old days